Alice here with us Alice congratulations
you're continuing the streak of
Victories and you're continuing to
maintain your lead in the tournament big
big game in this one how did you what
what was your strategy your mentality
coming into this game you're facing an
opponent that's struggling a bit in this
event did you want to put a lot of
pressure on her early on um yeah so I
had like the recipe to prepare and uh I
thought like
um because I'm like playing at White I
think I'm like the favorite here so I
wanted to try to like win this game and
maintain like the half a point lead I
have over the rest of the field
um especially since like tomorrow I'm
playing Chris up but yeah I'm very happy
with the way that the game turned out I
think I like outprepared her in the
opening and I think this was a critical
moment right after Bishop to C8 sure you
have the cup the two Bishops you have
some space Advantage but then this move
came along C5 really well timed break in
the center yeah so like uh first of all
I saw like my position was really good
even without D5 like even if I just say
like D5 and B4 I should probably be like
much better but C5 I thought um it's
just like really nice because
um at the very least uh I'm like
starting to take on B6 take on C and
also I can always like take on D7 play
C6 D5 and just completely drop the
bishop and
um so I saw e takes D4 was sort of force
yes um and after C takes B6 Rook takes
C3 Queen C4 teenage everything was
coming with tempo right you had the
option of maybe going B7 and picking up
the Knight what were you afraid of yeah
I mean I just thought like it'd be super
clean to take on D7 I uh since like all
the pawns a the a pawn and the d-pawn
they're both weak
um but I guess like I could have played
B7 this was the very mature way of
dealing in the composition don't give
your opponent any sort of counter play
well hell is another important victory
for you to uh keep ahead of your nearest
competitor Zoe tank seems to be winning
but there's one big result that's
happening right now is Carissa seems to
be losing against Rue Yang you're going
to be facing Carissa tomorrow she's very
far behind you so definitely she wants
to win how are you going to approach
that game big game
um yeah so I guess it's like I'll just
like try to take a uh and play my best
regardless of like the tournament
situation but it's sort of nice for me
that I have a bit of room for error
um because I have like this one and a
half point lead over her although Zoe
still only I think half a point behind
Zoe will be half a point behind you so
um it's again important for me to not to
lose uh and she'll definitely be
pressing for the win so I'll just have
to play my best chess there tomorrow
well we'll let you go back to your hotel
speak with your coach get the strategy
going and we'll see you tomorrow thank
you our congratulations as well Alice
very impressive game can I squeeze in
one oh sorry if Alice is still there
first of all congratulations great
convincing
International Chess Day and the 15th
anniversary of the Saint Louis chess
club and for the first time you tried
the duck chess so I do want to ask you
how did you enjoy the game oh yeah I I
really liked it it was like
um it was like so complicated
um it's like I think I put it as I am
Castilla and like he said the best
player C to move in advance so
um it's definitely a really unique way
of thinking with like the rubber ducks
as like another chess piece
um and I really like need to go study
some I guess opening Series there it's
just a really interesting game
especially like just a new way of
thinking like all your chest skills
previously
they're like not important when you have
that one extra duck piece
okay happy to hear that you enjoyed it
and
um yeah hope you continue playing
Duchess as well as actual Jazz yeah
and again the game of Carissa finishing